Sometimes I'm asked about how to resolve relationship conflict.
And I find this amusing and I'm smiling because this has never been a
strong suit for me, as it relates to intimate relationships,
I am not famous for my patients and have caused innumerable
problems in my relationships as a result of that,
and grew up at least through schooling and coaching with very little
positive reinforcement, a lot of negative reinforcement,
which also doesn't help matters.
But I have found a few different approaches and frameworks,
perhaps tools also that have helped me greatly personally,
to be a better partner to my girlfriend, for instance,
and also tools that help us together as a couple to
resolve conflict. It's not about avoiding conflict.
I think that there's a certain amount of conflict that can be avoided,
but whenever you are spending 24 seven together or in close proximity,
you are going to have friction in the system.
And that is certainly true with even my closest,
maybe especially my closest guy, friends,
but let's talk about the tools first.
I believe that to minimize conflict or quickly resolve,
like you need to first become more aware of your yeah.
Internal States and become more aware of the stories that you create
in your head,
the loops that you play that will inform how you interact with someone else.
Because if, for instance,
you create a story where you were always the victim and that is your pattern
that will greatly affect how you approach any type of conflict resolution or
discussion and two tools. I found very, very helpful for that. On number one,
Sam, Harris's waking up app. I highly recommend getting it.
I have no skin in the game, no equity, no pay off, no kickbacks, nothing.
So Sam Harris is waking up,
which provides a logical progression of skill development
in meditation, or really self-awareness that's number one,
it gives you a 10 minute practice each day that I, I do in the mornings.
I still use this app. I've run through it multiple times.
It's accepted that pairs very well with a book called awareness.
And for some reason it has multiple subtitles depending on the format.
One of them is I believe the promises and perils of reality,
the other is conversations with the masters,
but that doesn't make any sense because there's really only one author and that
is Anthony de Mello. So the book title is awareness, the author,
Anthony DeMello, D E M E L L O,
who was as a Jesuit priest and also a second therapist.
Very interesting combination.
And that book will also help you to recognize,
uh, the stories,
the movies you're creating as an interpretation of events.
It will also help you to become very bluntly,
honest with yourself in self-assessment, uh,
so that you are able to spot where you genuinely
want to fix problems or where you are more wedded to
drama, perhaps. And those two tools combined,
especially have been incredibly valuable for me. And that's kind of step one.
Uh, my girlfriend has also gone through both of these and it's helped us to
pause because between the stimulus and your response,
there is a gap and in the gap is where everything can
change. Uh,
that's where you get to choose your response to be response able. Okay.
So step number one is really working on your self to be a better partner.
Then as a couple, uh, thinking,
having a very candid assessment of your sensitivities and pet peeves
is very important. For instance, my girlfriend, at some point,
this was maybe six months ago, nine months ago asked me about wordsmithing.
She wanted to know how she could craft feedback in the perfect way.
She didn't phrase it that way, but in a better way,
such that I would be more receptive to certain types of feedback.
And we were doing a quarterly couples work,
which I also recommend. So having some type of facilitator, like a therapist,
at least once a quarter to assist with a
couples a day that we block out, we do this once a quarter.
And during one of those sessions, I said, it's not about the content.
It's about the timing. And I think this is true for a lot of couples,
rather than having things piecemeal throughout the day.
It is helpful for some of us, especially someone like me who is, uh,
wedded to structure and predictability as much as possible.
You might not think that might not expect that, but it's true on a daily basis,
I thrive with structure and I said,
it doesn't matter what the wordsmithing is. You could be,
you could be Tolstoy, you could be no buck off. It doesn't matter. I,
I need things to be timed in a particular way. Uh,
that would be my preference. And so we set aside on a say,
weekly or bi-weekly basis, a batching session,
and the batching session allows us to discuss what it is that
we need, uh, what it is that it's bothering us and the framework,
or I should say the format we've used.
And I am not aware of any reading we've done that has informed
this way.
It was trial and error is we first talk about what the
other person is doing. Well, what we love,
what we'd love more of right now, what we love more of is going to come again.
But what the other person, what our partners doing well, uh,
then we talk about what we think we're doing well personally.
And then we talk about what we would like even more of, okay.
Rather than saying what you're up, what you're up, what's driving me crazy.
It's like, you know what?
I would really enjoy more of what would really make me happy to get more of his
ex. And that type of very simple format has worked for us.
And it is recorded, not necessarily audio recorded,
but the, the takeaways, the homework assignments are recorded.
You could use something like Evernote.
You could use notes so that there's follow-up without follow-up.
This is all in the wind. So you need followups.
There are then the meeting notes,
so to speak from this batching session and we each get a copy.
And this way we can do two things, we can refer back to it.
So that for the next, at least several days,
following that batch batching session, refer to that,
say in the mornings as a reminder.
And then when we do our next batching session, we can see how we've done.
We can look at the, at the assignment and then the report card,
and sometimes I'll fall short and I'll be like, ah, God, you know,
I was supposed to do that. I totally blank. I'm so sorry.
There's an accountability. That is really important. All right.
So we've talked about a couple of things so far,
we talked about waking up at Sam Harris. We talked about awareness,
Anthony de Mello. We've talked about batching sessions.
And I also mentioned in passing these quarterly couples days,
it's an entire day set aside.
Let's just call it from like 10:00 AM to 8:00 PM,
something like that to talk and to have some type of facilitation.
And it can be very freeform in this case, there's less structure.
It's really just talking about whatever's on our mind. Whatever our wants are,
are our needs being met, are things bothering us, our, our desires, being that,
whatever it might be. And, uh, for me, at least, uh,
these tools and having this type of structure
has been invaluable. And last but not least as my friend,
[inaudible] one of the best investors and entrepreneurs I know has said,
and I'm going to paraphrase. Uh, if you want to avoid conflict,
step number one is, do not associate with people who are always in conflict,
right? So choose your friends, choose your partners very wisely.
You are going to be the average of the five people you associate with most.
So choose wisely. Good luck.